[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aurais pu vous parler de natation d'un
titre olympique qui se gagne à un
centième de seconde
un centième c'est une phalange j'aurais
pu vous parler de chambre d'appel bassin
de récupération mais j'ai choisi de
parler d'un point commun que nous
partageons tous ce soir et ce point
commun c'est celui d'être client d'une
banque en 1979 deux économistes français
prédisaient que la banque serait la
sidérurgie de demain près de quarante
ans plus tard les effectifs du secteur
bancaire ont été multiplié par 1,6
aujourd'hui encore les observateurs
prédisent la disparition des banques
alors c'est vrai que les banques peuvent
boire la tasse
pourquoi pas ce qu'elle doit faire face
aujourd'hui à trois nouveaux chocs d'une
ampleur considérable
premier choc un choc technologique les
banques font partie des premières
sociétés à s'être informatisé l'année
2012 mc marque un tournant c'est l'année
de l'intelligence artificielle
les performances des algorithmes en
matière de reconnaissance d'image sont
spectaculaires ce graphique reprend les
taux d'erreur des vainqueurs d'un
concours logiciels aux états unis en
matière de reconnaissance d'image il
s'appelle images nettes et le taux
d'erreur du vainqueur en 2012 a chuté de
10 points par rapport à celui de 2011
les taux d'erreur actuels sont de
l'ordre de 3% c'est-à-dire 40%
inférieurs aux taux d'erreur d'un être
humain
l'intelligence artificielle émules en
temps réel nos capacités cognitives
avec cette technologie le métier de mon
conseiller bancaire va être complètement
transformé
deuxième choc un choc de marché derrière
le terme de marché il y à l'offre et la
demande
trois familles de barbares attaque
actuellement les banques sur le plan
commercial première famille de barbares
les banques en ligne et les films tech
elle devait terrasser les banques
et finalement ce sont les banques qui la
rachète petit à petit deuxième famille
de barbares l'aîné aux banques elles
sont nées sur le mobile c'est le
cantique elle c'est au rangement qu il
est un peu tôt pour dire ce qui va se
passer mais le danger vient à coup sûr
une troisième famille de barbares les
géants de l'internet les fameux gaffe à
google amazon facebook et apple ils
grignotent des parts de marché sur les
paiements
il s'attaque progressivement crédit et
ce n'est pas fini
côté demande c'est à dire nous les
clients nous avons tous dans notre poche
un smartphone voire deux alors je sais
pas vous mais moi je passe plus de temps
avec mon mobile qu'avec ma famille le
monde du mobile
c'est un monde ouvert et intuitif c'est
le monde de la personnalisation et de
l'interaction moi m'ont conseillé il ne
m'appelle jamais manifestement il a rien
à dire sur l'écran de son ordinateur
je suis toujours ingénieurs et mon
épouse étudiante comme il ya 25 ans mes
filles
il s'en occupe pas et en plus il change
tous les trois ans les banques
tarbes a adopté les codes du monde du
mobile si elles le font pas elles
perdront le contact avec la clientèle
troisième choc un choc de réglementation
les banques sont rendus responsables de
la grave crise financière de 2008
la confiance est fragile elle est
largement entamée pour corriger cela
le législateur et le régulateur ont été
très productifs plus de 51000 texte en
2015 soit environ 140 textes par jours
week-end compris la conséquence mon
conseiller est devenu un robot il
applique des procédures à la lettre il
répond à des injonctions paradoxales
comme par exemple soient autonomes mais
en même temps respecte les règles
prendre des initiatives mais en même
temps respecte les procédures soient
agile mais en même temps quelqu'un
contrôlera ce que tu fais plus il ya de
règles plus la machine empiétera sur le
travail de mon pied alors avec ces trois
chocs technologiques marché
réglementation la banque ressemblera
demain à une machine froide
piloté par un superviseur entouré de
mathématiciens qui font des algorithmes
d'informaticiens qui met ses algorithmes
dans la machine et d'auditeurs qui
contrôlons tout ça mon conseiller sera
fait 2-0 et 2-1 sans visage sans coeur
sans chaleur et donc sans intérêt mais
est ce ce que est ce que c'est ce que
nous voulons nous les clients sont nous
prêts à faire confiance à des géants de
l'internet américain ou chinois que nous
ne connaissons pas et que nous ne voyons
pas les banques ont des atouts
j'en ai retenu trois premières à tous
leur dimension internationale
elles ont des filiales partout sur notre
planète
elles peuvent tout savoir sur les robots
en asie au japon en corée du sud ou à
singapour
sur la finance solidaire c'est en inde
sur le paiement sur mobile c'est en
afrique sur les monnaies alternatives
c'est en amérique du sud et sur les
technologies
c'est en amérique du nord il reste à
diffuser ses services innovants à nous
en europe
deuxième à tous leurs fichiers de
clients actifs
nous utilisons régulièrement les
services des banques elles collectent
tous les jours des milliards de
nouvelles données elles savent tout sur
nous sur le plan financier nous revenus
nos dépenses notre patrimoine
elles ont des clients professionnels
artisans commerçants
qu'attendent-elles pour nous mettre en
relation ce que moi si je quitte ma
banque je perds quoi alors c'est bien
beau de décréter la disparition des
banques mais ces observateurs avisés
sont ils seulement conscient de la
robustesse des systèmes informatiques et
de leurs tuyaux tri avant pour
cambrioler une banque
les malfaiteurs pousser la porte
aujourd'hui ils s'introduisent par les
réseaux informatiques
imaginez que votre compte bancaire soit
vidé imaginez que votre épargne
disparaissent imaginez que votre carte
bancaire soit bloquée pendant dix jours
ce serait les meutes assuré le troisième
atout des banques c'est leur sécurité
dans un monde où les transactions se
font sans se voir il est primordial
qu'un acteur joue le rôle de tiers de
confiance qui jouait ce rôle
au 19ème siècle c'était les concierges
au xxème siècle c'était les employeurs
qui aujourd'hui mieux que les banques
pourraient jouer ce rôle personne
alors à quoi ressemblera la banque de
demain l'un des gaffes à nous dit si
vous ne créez pas la chose qui va vous
tuer alors quelqu'un d'autre le fera
le seul hic c'est que les banques l'ont
déjà fait dans les années 2000 ces
pilules empoisonnées saper les subprimes
et pourquoi vouloir toujours tout
réinventer et si seulement la banque de
données ressembler à la banque d'hyères
ou à la banque d'avant-hier le banquier
de 20 sur un entrepreneur à l'écouté il
travaillera sur le long terme
mon conseiller me près maschera des
informations techniques pour m'aider à y
voir clair dans les évolutions de la
fiscalité il guidera mes filles dans la
gestion de leur argent au quotidien
le banquier de demain aimera ses clients
il sera plus humain comment y arriver
tout d'abord les banques doivent
redevenir des entreprises technologiques
c'est à dire à la pointe de la
technologie comme avant une question se
pose alors aux dirigeants où placer le
curseur entre le to machine et le tout
humain aux machines les héros les uns et
la puissance de calcul aux humains
la décision aux machines les
corrélations aux humains les causalités
aux machines
le tout venant aux humains la gestion
des exceptions et les imprévus
la période que nous vivons actuellement
est sans précédent dans l'histoire de
l'humanité les progrès technologiques
ont soulagé nos jambes nos bras nos
mains il s'attaque maintenant à notre
cerveau avec l'intelligence artificielle
nous sommes tous concernés
la colonisation du travail par la
machine touche tous les métiers ceux de
la banque le mien comme le vôtre alors
la prochaine fois que vous devrez cochez
cette case
prenez une minute pour trouver trois
arguments qui prouve que dans votre
quotidien et dans votre métier vous
n'agissez pas comme un robot un robot
sas copie et c'est interchangeables pas
un être humain merci merci bien
[Applaudissements]